marilla 15 dr. Larry Nasser will spend
the rest of his life in prison
more than 250 women and girls including
Olympic gymnasts accused him of sexual
abuse we spoke to the parents of five of
his victims Gina and John Nichols
daughter Maggie was a member of the USA
gymnastics team Lisa
Lorenza daughter Caylee was a club
gymnast Doug and Julie Powell's daughter
Cassie was a pole vaulter at Michigan
State University
Kyle Keizer took her daughter sterling
wreaths Minh to NASA after she was
injured and Kristi Lemke akio's daughter
Lindsey was first assaulted when she was
10 tempers erupted last week at NASA our
third trial and while the parents we
spoke with are angry they agreed the
biggest priority is to change the system
you were talking about an expletive
earlier Doug you are a hobby
we saw Randall margrave's Russian did
you understand where he was coming from
oh absolutely
absolutely if I thought that for a
second that would have done anything
positive to he was from me to you to
rush him and choke him out what goods
that gonna do me what's a good good was
that gonna do for Cassie we saw people
in many different stages of grief so
when we saw mr. margrave's at least for
my reaction I was just so sad I was just
so sad that it's like it's not my
reaction but I understood his because
you knew in the continuum of emotions
that we're all having we've all been
there
when your daughter's first told you
about this I mean was it hard for you at
first to believe them no no no it was
difficult for us you know we we talked
to our kids as they grew up and coming
from a law enforcement background in
perspective nothing ever good happens
after midnight you know go home don't do
this don't do this be conscious of what
you're doing
how do you guard from a doctor
how do you put that guard in your
daughter's mind it's it's the saddening
sickening I don't think for us it was as
much as not believing her but not
believing that something like that could
have happened I was in the room when he
was doing the treatment and he
positioned them such that I mean I even
stood up I'm a nurse I stood up to see
what he was doing and I said what are
you massaging right now and he said we
just have to loosen those tendons
ligaments muscles in that area and that
will help the scoliosis that you have in
your back can't see it told me
immediately when we got in the car she's
like I am never going back there again I
said why and she said he had his hand
inside me and he talked her back into
letting him do that he made it seemed
like without this area adjusted she
would never be able to be the pole
vaulter she wanted to be he had done
good work with her from the age 10 to 13
as a gymnast became a diver broke her
back as a diver had gone several places
for help and she was home on time and
I'm like let's go to Larry that was my
moment you know that he'd fixed her
before so it's beautiful
so when she went and had a broke we
don't even know what it is none of us
know broken back a broken tailbone so
when he described what he was going to
have to do and like it'll be pretty
invasive I'm going whatever we have to
do I want my child out of pain if this
is gonna work
let's go was it like knowing something
was wrong well for us it was horrible
because and for me I'm a failure
you know my job is to protect my baby
girl and I didn't do it and so that's
something that we're gonna live with
forever
we had no other choice you know we had
to turn our daughter over to the US
gymnastics we were told that we'll take
care of Maggie don't worry about Maggie
when we traveled that meets we couldn't
go to the hotel we couldn't stay at the
hotel we could not be in any situation
to help protect our daughter we had to
fully turnover trust
that was my design yes yes nor than just
to build these super competitors no
question
- what cover-up abuse I don't know I
mean I don't know but there's so much
more to this that needs to be found out
because each and every one of them are
intertwined senator jeanne Shaheen said
this is not a simple case of negligence
or failed oversight on the part of the
USOC
USA Gymnastics and other institutions
there is ample evidence that many were
alerted multiple times to Nasser's
behavior and they found excuses to look
the other way
yeah that's Kathy clay guess and people
at Michigan State who were alerted back
in the 90s and you know if you think
about it
Lyndsey would never have been abused had
they taken action back at that point
because she was only two not one of our
daughters no no when you look at this
collection right here
our daughters would not have walked
through those rights if other parents
come to you and say what should I do to
make sure this doesn't happen to my
daughter what do you what do you tell
them believer speak up yeah teach them
that if something doesn't feel right no
matter who it is to say I'm not
comfortable with this and I need you to
stop I think one other thing that you'd
tell your daughter you'd have to tell
them don't trust anyone you can't trust
the church you can't trust your priest
you can't trust your doctor my daughter
know not to trust anybody I think I want
to arm her with the tools that when
she's in the situation like I think had
I taught Kaylee to say I am
uncomfortable that I believe at 13 she
would have handled the situation
differently I want to ask quickly about
the Corollas they've received some
attention in this but how guilty are the
Corollas do you believe hundred-percent
guilty do you think they knew yes
because to me how could they not know so
have the Corollas been held accountable
no
we we know that they're being
investigated that's all we know about so
far figure the end I feel we've had one
person and who's that answer what do you
want to see happen to Larry Nasser I
know you don't to hear about Nasser I
don't think we care
I don't care about him because when you
aware of that more of the other people
that are culpable in all of this I think
that they need to either step up and
take responsibility or it needs to be
taken care of on that's what you said if
you could put in one hand all of those
institutions MSU USAG USO see if she
could put in this hand them coming to
her and genuinely you know picking her
up and giving her hug and saying I
screwed up so bad or our community
goofed up so bad if she had that in this
hand and 20 million dollars in this hand
she'd rather have this hand because her
psyche is just different and changed and
non trusting and that shouldn't be how
we have to live CBS News reached out to
all those the panel name the Corollas
who trained Olympic athletes at their
ranch have not responded they have said
they did not know about the abuse
Michigan State University and USA
Gymnastics also did not respond they
have said they did not attempt to hide
Nasser's misconduct the attorney for
former MSU gymnastics coach Kathy Clegg
has declined to comment citing ongoing
litigation spokesman for the u.s.
Olympic Committee said they are
launching an independent investigation
into the decades-long abuse by Larry
Nasser and I learned so much from
speaking to these parents and all just
incredible people and their daughters
are suffering so much abuse and the
aftermath of abuse lasts a lifetime and
because their daughters are suffering
they're suffering - as a parent the one
thing you never want to fail at is
protecting your children and while it's
not their fault you can see how they've
taken that all in and I had to tell you
my personal view is you know yeah is
there something they could have done the
daughters are the parents to protect her
guards I'm not sure they could have this
man was so sick and manipulative and the
onus lies on those eggs
negatives at the school and you
astronautic who knew about this for
decades and should have stopped it one
mother who was a person Ora reported it
the girls reported the behavior that
they felt uncomfortable about it the
woman who was a nurse in the room and
even she didn't know it shows how sick
he was and it was amazing to see the
tension in you know you don't want to
teach your children to trust no one
because then you're coming out of this
the the lesson is treat everything like
a barren scape of no human contact I
mean that's if that's the solution
that's yeah it's what's so tough about
that but this is going to continue
because more people need to be held
accountable that's the only way to make
sure it doesn't happen I know to
continue yeah that was really good
really good